[Music]
i don't comment anything
i do not leave comments i'm totally
lazy about it and i'm sorry everyone who
has to read my code because it is
completely wild west on your own figure
it out from the code
too bad
i comments nothing
the code is the comment
yeah
writing too many comments
[Music]
well um i could reduce the verbosity i'm
still trying to learn but i because i
like to um go back to my code oftentimes
i feel like it's just
um like if you come back to a quote a
couple of months later you'll probably
have no idea what you did but i like to
kind of think about that in
that
mitigating that problem in the future
and try to write some comments and
documentation sometimes the like
variable names i use have no meaning
they're just placeholders and you know
that's okay but
it helps when you're like actually
deploying something or you have
something that you're trying to share
with other people to have
something that has meaning instead of
just a
t or an x i also am really really bad
about
um going back and
cleaning up my code
it's a bad habit generally in research
my worst programming hack a habit is to
always take
someone's like a research code base and
start cleaning it up and try to make it
like
remove all of the boilerplate code for
like checkpointing like uh parameter
management
uh and all of those and basically plug
in all of my own like open source
packages um because it slows me down
initially but i think like it does make
like a clean code base is important for
moving really quickly and for like
communicating like clearly with their
collaborators and like with the others
like working with their code i i
really dislike when stuff is not
structured but uh when code is not
structured well but then obviously when
you're sort of just starting on
something there is always that
temptation to or there's this trade-off
between you know spending too much time
structuring things versus just getting
it working and so i definitely
have found that pet peeve just by doing
it myself and you know being frustrated
at myself looking back you know why did
i not uh sort of organize this better
and now i'm sort of wasting time trying
to figure out what it was i was doing a
year ago
not going to sleep when i should so
problems seem to become just like
astronomically more difficult as the day
wears on
and i think that really the answer is to
go home at five o'clock or six o'clock
uh and forget about it and look at it
again the next morning um but like you
know all of us uh i'm a busy grad
student i want to make progress
sometimes i get excited about what i'm
building and so i'll stay up super late
working on it uh and i'll typically find
that those six hours that i might spend
in the evening uh are terrible i
introduce a ton of bugs into my code i
find like problems just insurmountable
and then i'll go to sleep and be like oh
nothing works and i'll wake up the next
morning and fix it in you know 10
minutes
so
trying not to do that
[Music]
you